YouTube Facebook LinkedIn okay all right
I'm ready to have people come in its and
then I guess right I put out some a text
on my community that I know a lot of you
are part of and I had people in the
cubes with questions from that platform
and now I'm going live URL is in my all
right show up so Gary how are you doing
well doing well my questions how are you
keeping your clients calm and still
motivated do business all while being
empathetic everyone's situation out
there right now I mean just
communication just trying to mind people
that money isn't end-all-be-all like
it's all about really relationship well
it's not how you eat money all the time
then you have a much better chance of
actually getting them to be okay
right like if I said to you like hey and
like you're not going to be hold on once
again right Instagram going the URL is
in my profile right now if you want to
watch a slide you know if you're the
place where I'm like hey bro like look
you're gonna lose that beautiful tree
painting behind you and like you're not
gonna live in the same you know house
and things that nature all of a sudden
if the person isn't scared about that it
gets a lot easier so I'm a big fan of
like worst cases in it walls and so when
people start freaking out like some have
I might wanna what like
else like like wow you know like your
you know I think it's a it's a game of
worst case scenario
right now we've had some clients that
have had a let us go because I just
don't have the money we have a lot of
uncertainty going into these next you
know 12 to 24 weeks but to me ultimately
I go into a place where I'm like your
media business and I'll start over like
I don't know how to get scared by money
I really I'll be honest with you that's
that's really it trying to get my
employees my partners my vendors and my
clients to not be scared of that money
when they start freaking out couple did
this week you know like just getting
people okay with that letting them
comfortable awesome thank you how about
for you what are you doing what's going
on in your head I saw sunroom skylights
conservatories have residential side and
commercial sky side the RET residential
side we're still going coral side I saw
the restaurants and hotels and it's just
completely stopped and what was that a
big percent of your business fair amount
yeah so I'm 34 spend I am a little
worried but at the same time I feel like
I made through 2008 I can make it
through anything
how many please do yet I'm self-employed
yeah wouldn't you biggest expenses
mortgage yeah got the red car payment
but again haven't gone through 2008
tighten my belt last time I was over
leveraged two houses in a condo this
time I'm good like that so it's just
about like kind of like like quality I
didn't call colleague like I call it
quality of fancy I think that's the only
thing that potentially gets tight and
right yeah yeah
so are you is your question based on how
you wanted to conversate with some of
your hotel and restaurant owners just
everyone you know like people are
listening to 24-hour news cycle nothing
but negativity and you know we get out
there and they're there any bombarded
with all this trash in their head and
you know it's one talk to you see how
you keeping your clients going and take
it from there it's funny like I don't I
don't overly think that the news cycle
is crash in the same way that I don't
think the people on social media that
are like this is a mean [ __ ] it's the
answers always in the middle right right
yeah be practical like you know like a
lot of these things are are real right
now and like there's a lot of
practicality that is required around
something like this and that is like you
know no matter how much of a bailout the
government creates you know there's
gonna be so many of us in small
businesses that are we're not going to
get our and so I'm just gonna have you
said the experience of 2008 the
experience of 2001 for help I'm a little
bit concerned for people that I've never
been through any of this and helping
them try to navigate it
you know you were a young dog and
over-leveraged you know we learned that
lesson that's why you watch it so it's
just about over communicating keeping it
in the middle and I think the answer
that I gave you up front is the insulin
if you don't over value money that's
what's up thanks again and I'm like
listen you don't have to have a car
maybe you take public transportation
like you don't have to own
maybe you rent an apartment like people
people are no nobody's owed anything and
it honey and bought $13 cocktails and
went on eight thousand dollars to help
you through a rainy day the consequences
are you losing things that's the way it
should be in a lot of ways yeah
you've been warning everyone about this
for a minute you know because it can
look not because I'm smart and
definitely not cuz I know it's coming
please
not just how like this cycles right
nothing you know and just disable all so
anyway I appreciate bro talk to you soon
thanks for being that you see it all
right Dustin I know you're on the other
side thanks Adam thank you this handsome
man off Dustin get me to my next lesson
alright alright for everybody our son in
my own right now Dustin like while you
make sure these super super good hope
that make some sense to you oh it's good
hey what's going on Gary good morning
morning what's going on oh not much I
masks and you're getting ready to start
the day here in a few minutes how are
you doing today mom where are you
oh just outside Buffalo New York I'm
well thank you for being on what can I
get you no thank you
so my question is what's the best way
you found if you have found on how to
get clear really what you really want in
life I'm like amid all the doorways and
the prettiest positions and all that
stuff like how to listen to what what
you really want who's carrying the most
who's carrying the most volume in your
head besides you well I moved to him to
he'll take care of it there
for like health reasons and some
financial stuff for them but I've gotten
to the point where I got that pretty
well tied up and now it's where I can
start focusing on me more so a lot of
it's been that okay and so first of all
that's amazing
like I'm stuck you know obviously with
my life story of going into my family
business to build it after them and I
just admire so much when people have
this right to go back home and have
parents whether it's health or financial
and whatever other reasons so I really
thank you you know yeah I agree
how pumped you were going into it or how
[ __ ] the grudge and you were going
into it
yep yeah um are you saying that you've
got to restart now and recalibrate and
like remember what the [ __ ] you know
some of the concepts and perceptions and
ideas parents may have might have seeped
you know I'm fortunate that they were
never they've never been like oh you
should go do this because you'll be
successful like that message very much
resonates the u.s. talking about so my
friends I've seen but I've really been
free to kind of make up my own mind as
far as that goes but God gave me give me
more context yeah I was gonna say
basically when I got into school that's
when kind of [ __ ] started in the fan
with them so I took a job where I could
work in remote sales to be here help
them out and now that's kind of where I
have this freedom to more focus on me
and what I want to do and I know I want
to go to business for myself one day but
I've been having a hard time in figuring
out exactly in what in what exactly
let's talk about you the like Charlie
like what what do you [ __ ] with sports
music cooking travel like what do you
like I think the people actually you
know first book I real crush it or leave
it sound okay I think this internet
things about to be big and I think
actually in essence what I recently said
was I think right like or vlogger thing
the first place
the business unique in hindsight like I
think one of the reasons cards just
because I like it and I'm trying to take
my own map which is like you'll always
do better and things like more yeah what
do you like yeah I mean I love like
schemes like my like that's my favorite
thing to do I love skiing you played
football through most of my life so I
love sports do but it kind of always
came second but I do love helping people
like it's really cool like when I can
help someone and then it changes their
life whether it's some business or what
have you
like my parents lately immediately I go
into this idea of like this business
one-week ski school that is only we need
like a week as well you know and it's
like this
the psychology resort you know like some
people like to go to a spa for four days
and cause I think that needed something
called like cleanse with powder oh my
god it's a business except for you know
come up to Vermont
it's a week you know you get seven days
of skiing
whether you're it's called will help you
it's 20 people max you've got all pay X
and it's a day of skiing and then we all
have dinner together we [ __ ] then
there's one on one kind of like yeah
like if you actually have that helping
you know it's kind of like what I'm
doing man I like what I didn't realize
was I was gifted with the ability to a
lot of ideas very quickly which is why I
just did now right like listen to you
and come up with a genuine concept like
the videos done and YouTube like
they're all really work right like like
making videos being and like you talking
about like things that you like to talk
about like pumping out parents or being
a millennial or like you know never like
don't be like just not my lead I speak
all the time in my lane right and so I
think I think isness around helping
people by being a lemming year and a
little community is it absolutely no I
very much agree with you there now you
know how you always talk about the whole
like like screw money concept like money
money isn't happiness right so I did a
good job in getting in a good amount of
student debt so I've been I've been
playing that game so when I hear that I
know suppose did I mean there's no
reason I couldn't do it better right but
I don't see it I can see it being a
constrictive it like not being able to
essentially afford my current situation
look you're talking to somebody who for
12 years of his life did something I was
still briefing for them you know if you
spend 70 years you grow in a high to
clear that there's nothing wrong with me
and then starting [ __ ] and you know a
sweet with powder yep the truth hey I
like that name better I'm trying to
iterate here so you know there's there's
also the ability to go and literally ask
every person you know for five 10 15
thousand dollars to be able to raise
capital ask a thousand people you get 10
yeses now you've got a little bit of a
base to start the business and if the
business is a business of a sudden
you're using the profits sales just a
lot of ways to attack like I don't think
there's any right way it was just a
right way to charm his DNA and wasn't
you [ __ ] eighty years in front of you
is a really big factor yeah thank you
for that I just made me think of
something did you appreciate it so I got
laid off two weeks ago from my sales job
missed this whole thing and basically
what my plan was today is I made a list
of sales leaders of companies I'd like
to work for and I was gonna cold call
someone myself do you think that's a
good move in this time right now or do
you think it's insensitive I'm a big fan
of a customizable cold meal and thin and
cold diem and cold call when people who
do that nine percent of the time always
nine percent time because they don't
make it to connection to that person so
when you do your homework on her if your
email title starts with like you know
just like Albert who host I can you know
hit home runs are you that matters
yeah people always like I'm gonna help
you buy the Jets delete because it's I
hear that a million times
now Carol may not hear anybody ever
mentioned the Cardinals so I think it's
a great idea I think you know sitting
around and dwelling is a bad idea
something yourself is a great idea I
think I'm trying to make sure you
actually get the job and so I think you
have to do the extra 15 to 45 minutes of
research call more effective because
going for of aged yeah no absolutely I
appreciate that thank you Gary
have a great day yeah you do take care
while we transition to the next Paul I
just want to give a huge shout out to be
berries I think B berries are grossly
grossly underrated and so so there's
that yes yes I do
- according
you
you
good morning hey I'm good I'm all the
way in Southern Oregon so it's early
here like when you talk about
self-awareness all the time I'm just
like then it blows my mind cuz I just
feel like I've always been there and
it's awesome to be here so I just want
to give a shout out to your team because
I know how much work it is to do audio
and video work so just props to them too
anyway so my question as a parent
actually every year I kind of pick like
a word instead of like a thing that's
like a New Year's resolution I guess you
could say and my word this year is
gratitude so I've been thinking a lot
about instant gratification with like
Internet we're able to get on our phones
we can get into anything and I know you
love technology I love technology but
with our kids they can get on our phones
and just do anything and go anywhere and
get it instantly and we didn't have that
life so you know how good it is
how do we show our kids that gratitude
and how good we have our lives daily you
know we have such good things always
happening kind of just like easily well
you know it's funny
like to your point we didn't have the
internet or or the speed of which--it
what we had but like we had to be a VCR
and our grandparents we were lucky we
had Nintendo and I thought that was
crazy because they had to go to the
arcade so you know to me I don't think
getting kids to be grateful is
predicated on making them feel lucky
about what they have because that's just
a reality you know I think gratitude
comes from actually devaluing things
other than health and happiness you know
I think the old-school grandmas and
grandpas that would just like health and
happiness had it down I think you know
that's what I spend time on so to me
it's really more about um to meet
that's good yes you've seen the good
things going down I think it's about
clapping up and making a bigger deal of
like time together like I think parents
are not patient about the deposits
they're making with kids like if you if
you celebrate dinners together if you if
you celebrate just talking hugging like
if you if you celebrate the right things
those things are being instilled in your
kid what parents struggle with is that
they don't see the instant results of
that it's always long-term you know I
think what parents struggle with is they
want like their kids to like flip the
switch and be grateful see now that
there's Korona be grateful for what you
have right the reality is it's not how
it works what you need to still
gratitude around not an Xbox or you have
a roof over your head around like we
love each other thank God everybody's
healthy we love each other thank God
everybody's healthy and you just stay
consistent and then yeah when they're 27
they kind of over one night over dinner
or they they're like hey mom thanks for
doing the net and that's it like I think
most parents are looking for instant
results for kids and kids are not those
kind of animals you'll see them you'll
see the results of that good work that
consistent deposit of the right
perspective you'll see that in their
twenties and thirties right uh yeah I
definitely feel that because I say to my
parents I'm like I get it now cuz my you
know trying to discipline the you out of
your own kid is like it's so frustrating
no damn it I remember doing that same
thing and it's also putting those things
into perspective I think a lot of
parents over worry about other parents
opinions like I think well that I'm
focused on is like if it if I believe it
then then that's what it is not if I'm
worried about what the fellow teachers
or other parents are gonna say about it
yeah I know that's kind of what my word
last year was like kind of like
forgiveness for you
myself or like what you talk about
putting yourself in self imposes jail I
think I put too many freaking
expectations on what Parenthood and what
my life was supposed to be and then all
those like came crashing to Holt because
you know how it is with kids nothing you
ever thought it was gonna work is what
happens nothing you ever thought was
gonna be the way it was is what it is
everything that you put in the further
expectations with a child is it is
definitely changed by they're they're
coming into the world you deliver that
sentence is mmm you need to [ __ ]
realize your life has kind of weirdly
just started to like oh yeah in a good
way I'm like yeah like you know like you
know like the way was supposed to be
your things that nature like yeah you
actually have a lot more time to make
[ __ ] happen and I think that when we
ideologic when we're ideological at 16
13 12 we're thinking about the 20 30 40
but you know no Colonel Sanders the guy
cream the Gray Goose these people
started their true calling in their 40
50 60 70 s elites yeah I tell myself
that all the time because I'm gonna I'm
about to be 35 and I got my bachelor's
degree in costume design so that's my
other thing yes I started being a media
34 and started in another company it's
conference room because I didn't have
enough you know it's totally I keep
thinking that I'm like you Oprah I keep
telling myself this is the time where I
can get started and and buckle down like
because my perspective is totally
focused in the right direction now
because I realize you know my kid is
everything to me
and if I want her to do what she wants
to do in life and be happy in that world
I have to do it if I don't show her yeah
I love what I do she's not gonna see
that and she's not gonna want to be the
same thing I want to give her the car
by having the confidence in myself well
I mean self-awareness
I'm the second of six kids I just like
my siblings do it my my dad school of
hard knocks he built houses I saw I was
out on job sites and that's a kid in
Florida it's hot I was like I want to
work smarter not harder I love
construction I love watching things work
so I just want to you know show her that
she can build anything she wants to I
love that Yujin it's really really glad
we connected right sure carry a little
connecting more I just feel it don't you
see bye Gary thanks for getting up so
early annoyed oh hey I want
all right let's do it okay
hello hey deadly tranch little girl
either
what's up Gary are you I can't see you
but I'm good you see me I can't now are
you I'm good glad you got your stock of
blueberries yes some raspberries also
one critical that's critical master make
some good wine yeah thanks for taking
this time see I might be a little legacy
story to this but basically I'm 37 and
started an ant farm competition on
tik-tok Wow and exactly it's the same
thing I get from everybody else so we
went from 0 to 70 K followers mm-hmm and
the span of maybe it was like 2 or 3
weeks and then now it's kinda round 70
going into the first month right you
won't see him please
all right here we go ready there's a
rope so there's the box the garyvee box
of course got Rosa Antonius in there
we've got four key yeah it's an ant farm
basically three oh it's the funniest
thing in the world but up me yelling
about tick-tock and jumped in or was
there a different reason jumped in yeah
so I've been hearing you for the past
four five years I started a little
hundred a day workout challenge about a
year ago just listening to you listen a
podcast pushing on your podcast learned
a ton from that got it was the fear of
looking into the camera okay I'm right
now so this is really hard for me but
it's really fun so 100 a challenge come
help me get through the fear of looking
at the camera and I've been looking at
dick talk for like three or four months
and I'm like you know what the office is
doing an ant farm competition just for
like lowering stress we just getting a
bunch of these ant farms having fun
looking at ants and it's like a really
good way just to get out of the
day-to-day like software industry I work
with a partner for sa P and implementing
the ERP software for process
manufacturing so it's definitely a job
and this is just fun so it started as a
side thing I've just been looking as you
mentioned just looking into tik-tok and
just kind of watching and just basically
just looking at the content and see
seeing where this would fit and like
where would ant farms fit and then
nobody's doing what I'm doing it's just
basic but that's kind of what I was
going for is its long-form it's one
minute a lot of things are 15 seconds on
tick tock
so I'm actually building an audience
it's a lot of fun and people aren't
enjoying it and I'm finding the tick
tock community even it's a little
younger very authentic they really
appreciate common thing are you thinking
about turning it into a viable business
you know what like I've been tasting for
quite some time as you'd mentioned I got
the martial arts for 10 years I made a
song the Hedgehog video game played
poker online like I'm all over the board
so I've been trying to yeah yeah so I'm
trying to find the things go ahead do
you there's a positive I mean that good
yeah I've been trying really hard to
find like what is the actual thing that
makes me tick you you you do view that
as a positive the poker and the Sun
hundred percent because a lot of people
I think take the judgment of others who
like oh you're always trying random [ __ ]
like boggle down and you know like all
those conservative you know
straight-laced
stay in the pocket you know misery loves
company voices that we all have in our
lives that I'm carry too much weight so
I'm proud of you for realizing doing all
that random [ __ ] the effort and humility
to find actual happiness is huge bravery
and something I just admire quite a bit
so good for you thank you sir so yeah so
basically getting into this and I just
basically took the plunge and just put
it on tik-tok just had a ton of fun with
it and people are really grasping to it
which is great so now we're at 70 K and
yeah could I have a viable business that
I go to like monetize it somehow
actually I could if some of the ant farm
companies reaching out to me like wow we
called you fuller sales like what the
heck is going on but for me like I have
a full time
and I have three kids of a two-month-old
upstairs and my kid just got up so I'm
doing this at nighttime I'm basically
taking quick videos while I'm on
conference calls just like this and then
I'm making funny voice just having a
great time I'm having the most fun I've
ever had so the growth is there the
naysayers are definitely there and I'm
happy to say hey you know what guess
what I'm having fun another naysayers
are coming around naysayers like
publicly anonymous these years were like
no internal like more just my circle
which is crazy
what's amazing like this is it's not so
much this I mean it's more of like all a
the little dumb things I want to do it's
like the little neg like the hundred
days challenge oh why are you wasting
your time on that just maybe general
around the people I'm around it's like
why are you wasting time there were race
time on your business you got three kids
you know so I'm finding time it's fun
it's getting traction now people like
wow they're paying attention to the ants
you know kind of funny so where do I go
from here the question you definitely go
on YouTube
you definitely definitely definitely
have to make youtube videos you have to
you you definitely go on Facebook I even
know people don't think about Facebook
these days I think the opportunity there
I think you go on Twitter well you're
what you need to you won't get the viral
growth anywhere else this is why I'm
concerned my [ __ ] lungs like going
tick-tock did a good job how many videos
a day are you putting on tick-tock at
least three to four basically I've been
following your exact like I've watched
your time he's gonna take back and I
just post right after you basically
listen you know I've said it a bunch
watch what I do not what I say I
appreciate by now so where do you go
from here I think that I think there's a
lot of places you can go from here the
number if I was in you know the basement
with you and we were buddies from high
school we're like ok Gary like you're
[ __ ] good business student like help
me I would first say what kind if
everything went perfect if I was the
[ __ ] ant farm genie of the few how
would you want to monetize this part of
the world do we want to sell $90 kits do
we want to have a referral business do
we wanna you know make you face
so you're giving presentations at kids
birthdays like like passionate about is
for example that last one for a lot of
people that's like silly or like sounds
stupid but like you don't happy some
magicians and performers at kids parties
aren't and I know actors that have gone
on to like build viable businesses some
of them are doing two three hundred
thousand in appearances and doing
million between YouTube ads and kits
they sell and they [ __ ] magic so
that's cool I love kids so I think for
me
it comes down to the number one place
there's two things you do for sure one
is you distribute the content in other
places even much smaller growth they
lead to other opportunities
press on CNN which gen changes your
awareness YouTube leads to a search
result that pops and now you're gonna
give up one video that has a million
views on it for years that really is
your rules there's a lot of reasons
people are too caught up just in
following count without realizing other
things that go into success I'm social
which is really mean which leads to
brand which leads to business but I
think the biggest thing we need to
figure out is in a perfect world how do
we how do we turn this into something
that to me I would literally this is
where I don't want to put your business
out there you're mortal allowed to share
if you want but it would be how much do
you make in a year
and how do we get to that number with
the ant farms so that you could actually
do this full-time I really think that
way yeah yeah no I couldn't really
disclose I want to make obviously but
yeah for sure the process manufacturing
ERP space takes up a lot of time and
it's just it's a service based business
and I know you know and I'm trying to
keep in the same building as vaynermedia
in New York so I know I showed up and
tried to knock on your door it didn't
work I mean I think look I think extra
hours at night I mean this is [ __ ]
crush that's all I'm doing
yeah question I have
your signed copy thank you 62nd close so
I mean that book was written twelve
years ago and you're literally living
that like I am you know you got a two
month old maintain your real life
they'll take ya where you can on the
side and build this thing up but I bro
just the authentic happiness you're
talking about what they say by the way
what the [ __ ] the authentic story have
put it like if you came up like I think
you could build a multi-million dollar
b2b business of HR executives buying ant
farms for that exactly because authentic
like we did this like if your story day
in and day out just like Mike the reason
I want an entrepreneurship was there was
a purebred entrepreneur of the eighties
their lemonade yeah he started this to
get a seven to twelve minute mental
healthy break in a dragon I could see
you selling unlimited amounts of these
ant farms to HR executives on LinkedIn I
mean you should make LinkedIn only
videos I have are you at a place yet
where you can sell some of these ant
farms were you or or other people have
them and that's why their sales have
gone up have you struck an affiliate
sales deal have you thought about
building your own so I have struck a
small affiliate sales deal it's not
fully inked yet but I basically like
yeah so that's already happened I just
reached out I think you should make a
couple of videos from LinkedIn be
authentic is [ __ ] like literally the
videos like hey LinkedIn this is me I'm
at this ERP like you know here this is
the end part let me tell you the story
like literally story time story time
yeah talk about and now I've is Deb Dan
now I have an affiliate deal and here's
the link to those people like yeah
transparent with the audience I would
twenty to fifty of those one for HR
executives one for the individual stay
at home business person I would make
twenty to fifty LinkedIn videos this is
the perfect broke this coronavirus isn't
crazy it's a blessing it's gonna force
people to cry and [ __ ] that they would
have never done to actually you know how
many business I've been talking about a
morning show called tea with Gary
in a show first I'm there something that
I want to do that I haven't been able to
do so I would definitely do the LinkedIn
thing just to see what happens yeah yeah
I started like they only got my little
light kit I started to make like ERP
tips videos just to get myself out there
so anything any traction yet how many
have you done I just started like legit
just started two days ago
yeah so it's working Wow
so I mean email like a week or two and
just put an turn while we do 100% hey
one quick thing when I come to New York
can I come value at nes hockey are you
good at it why would I even ask that
question if I didn't have that cred I
mean I'm in send an email right now -
Gary yes farm and I'll get you to take
care of it you're the man he won't last
quick thing it should so that my aunt
one thing is like a bachelor Meets The
Hunger Games meets like me being Steve
Hart receiver and blade should I just
stay on that track just have a ton of
fun haven't you done it listen I don't
know if you heard it when you were
talking about getting over being on
camera
I said quickly while you were talking
you're good at it I think you're good at
it well thanks have you watched one it
gives me enough preciate I think yes all
right
cool will save time to those thanks gay
have a good day okay
let's keep it going Destin I saw
you
what's your name
hey can you guys see me can you guys
hear me what are you I'm doing great how
are you guys
super well what's your question so I
have been I've been working in the
exotic animal your question like all I
want to do is go on that bookshelf
behind you and look up that's my
cherished reference library thank you so
much so my husband and I have been in
the exotic animal hobby since the 90s we
started our YouTube channel about seven
years ago so our initial goal and we
also decided to move from hobby to
business around that time so we started
our YouTube channel in 2012 and he's the
Big Idea guy and I'm the detail person
so together I consider us to be quite an
epic force and so basically we've been
growing our channel very very slowly for
a long time and sort of our backbone has
been creating the highest quality
content possible consistently and so our
channel has very slowly grown to 50 K so
one of the strategies we've been doing
the last maybe three years is being
super faithful to our social media so
that started off really heavily being
Facebook and now it's moved more toward
Instagram although I still do post a
Facebook daily and then starting in
December after we kind of got hooked to
listening to you in the fall we also
started on tik-tok and all that's
growing very slowly but we had a video
go somewhat viral last year and so that
kind of that that grew us from about 20k
to maybe 40k I wouldn't say quickly but
within four months maybe and now we're
at about 50 got it okay keep yeah
on YouTube yeah so basically we we feel
like our growth has has really kind of
come to a skidding halt we just kind of
want to know where you would suggest we
go from here okay so a couple things so
I the growth is not necessarily a
skidding halt if you started at seven
years ago and less than a year ago you
had a video that more than doubled your
reality right okay I think it's I think
the growth off of that viral video has
maybe stopped but if you look at it in
the macro you've had more growth in the
last year than you did in six years
prior combined so you're okay you
probably have more growth going on right
now than you've had for seven years yeah
good point
well that's number one putting into
perspective number two is I'm less
worried about how many subscribers one
has I'm more worried about one what one
wants out of it and so have so is your
hope and dreaming that you have millions
of subscribers so that the ad revenue
from YouTube is the monetization or are
you hoping to monetize in a different
way or or or are you is your business
good enough and this is more of a you
know competitive vanity part of it that
you want the following to be higher okay
so our our ideal hope for YouTube is
twofold number one to grow our business
and number two I'm sorry the business oh
so so our business is we breed and sell
exotic animals primarily reptiles and
invertebrates mainly tarantulas and it
was through the awareness people reach
out and buy trenchless or other reptiles
from you yes so and to educate is kind
of our primary goal but to monetize the
ation of our channel to grow and also to
grow our business at this point my
husband and I are both still working
full-time he works in the medical field
I'm a schoolteacher and so our next
phase is basically probably for him to
start running the business
full-time it's not supporting itself at
this time we another thing we started
was an only fans account and that's gone
pretty well so far so that's actually
bringing in some revenue so that's also
been a kind of interesting because we
have kind of a fan base that's more a
fan of me than the business and so yeah
that's been interesting I I model and
dance and so that's been like basically
I just started that in December and
they've our fans have already paid for
us to go to Chicago our next trip for a
big reptile expo so that's been a whole
nother like separate thing words we're
trying so long story short we would want
our channel to grow in order to bring
revenue from our channel also to educate
to grow our business and bring in
revenue how many hours have you spent on
trying to get educated on titling and
thumbnails of your videos on YouTube how
many hours have you or your husband put
in don't bother
probably 20 which sounds like a real
shame in all these years honestly
honestly you'd be surprised how many
people are seven years in and are at
zero mmm
you know so hey I would definitely spend
more time on that okay 20 to 45 minutes
every day okay about that
I do think Facebook Ads would work okay
yeah we haven't okay so I do think
Facebook Ads
have a sneaky potential I just Facebook
Ads work extremely well well let me ask
you question are you more interested at
this point to grow the fanpage
subscription business or the selling of
the reptiles if you like had your way
definitely selling the reptiles is
certainly more of an interest and I
would be a little bit sad if if our
reptile business never became successful
but we can support our hobby because I
was modeling I mean that that that would
be that would be great but ideally our
our business would I'm just kind of
doing that in the meantime and also too
I'm not young so I don't know how long
that's gonna that's gonna keep floats so
I think I think that I think running ads
to of like incredible photos of
tarantulas and reptiles on Facebook and
finding the right target do you have a
good I mean is is it a business I mean
I'm guessing here is it predominantly
male buyers of course so like is there
an age group or is it really well begin
it um so it does kind of run the gamut
so it's I would say though predominantly
like late 20s to mid 40s yes so this
starts exciting me right like you start
going on Facebook you go twenty-five to
forty two mm-hmm there might be some
interest paid you know that you could
wrap this to I don't know if there's you
know I don't know if it works on you
know whether it's believe this or not
whether there's bands that over like is
is our people that are into metal more
likely to also collect like I'm trying
to think of like cross over ice over
yeah there's there's definitely with
like rock music and tattoos and reptiles
and things like that so I would run like
a Facebook ad against 25 to 40 year old
fans of harley-davidson and then and
then run the tarantula photo like the
best photo you can come up with yeah and
and then and then a video ad and then a
picture at I think Facebook will
surprise you Instagram ads - I think
Instagram and Facebook
think about this you very visually
interesting product mm-hmm like if
you're into this that's gonna stop you
in your screen when you see the photos
of all right there's a scalable sales
it's very simple I have no idea how much
profit you make on per tarantula but how
much is
I mean they can vary wildly from $5 to
$400 so let's say that there's a hundred
dollar tarantula that we make I'm just
gonna make this up we make the kind of
it on okay you can find that Facebook ad
that costs you $23 to convert somebody
aka it cost you two dollars and 30 cents
per every interest click and one out of
every ten people thus you're spending
twenty three dollars to get them but
your dollars in profit you just start
running the [ __ ] ads as heavy as you
can that is what you're looking for in a
Facebook and Twitter Facebook
environment I believe that's sitting
there for you it's gonna take the
ability to figure out that it's
twenty-five to thirty seven-year-old
harley-davidson fans you've got to
figure that out but once you've got that
it can become quite scalable okay
awesome
hope you think is I was just wondering
is there like a specific like search
engine technique or website that you
used to try and get that data
no it's about actually coming up with
the ideas like we just did here okay the
Facebook ad product you go into the ad
you know program on the back end of both
Facebook and Instagram and you'll see
the selectors and the query reason and
the way to navigate that no different
than when used to buy SEO ads or
anything like that okay awesome well I
just want to say I'm a big fan and I'm
so honored that you took the time to to
answer my question personally today
you're the man thank you you as well
let's keep this going
awesome Yuri Kim how are you good how
are you can you hear me
hey gay what's up a man first of all a
moment of gratitude man you know I've
been consuming your content for a little
bit not too too long but I just want to
thank you from the bottom of my heart
because I feel like you've given away so
much just free information is so much
value to people you know and it's been
amazing to listen to this information
and then some of that is just
motivational you know you your big
reason why I just started my youtube
channel and Instagram channel about
exercise and fitness and you know
listening to you I realize you know why
not well what is holding me back you
know so just thank you so much man I
really appreciate it man my first
question pertains to quality versus
quantity of content that you post I just
got a PDF of your website about 64
pieces of content that you recommend
people put on on a daily basis so I
wonder where do you find that balance
you know how much do you like how do you
determine content quality versus quality
so for me quantity is not debatable
right meaning
19:18 that's the number mala tea is very
debatable right you know for example
what are some people that don't think
that would you know this right now I'm
not using lighting yesterday on Twitter
like yeah you look terrible like not
just lighting and eye bags into my eyes
because my family's DNA you know Eastern
European [ __ ] you understand that you're
so like you know like me quality is
subjective
you know people overthink quality on
production value I think quality is
based on the words coming out of my
mouth right now so for me the way I look
is people use quality often as an excuse
not to do its the thing they say because
they don't actually want to put
themselves out there and quantity is not
debatable in quantities more at-bats and
I think it is a volume game on the
Internet
and because of the nature of the
Internet so for me how do i balance it I
don't put out anything that I don't
think is quality but I don't think
production value or image quality is
quality I think the message and the
words or the quality not the package its
deliberative understood understood the
next thing is the brand name itself
obviously building a brand is so
important today in today's world so just
to give you an example the YouTube name
is learn to exercise but the Instagram
name learn to exercise is taken so how
important it is to have the exact same
name is it is it okay to have some
underscores and things in the name okay
names and handles are made I'm Gary Vee
with to silent ease that's not smart it
should have been Gary Vee and no EE but
I made it through my actions
McDonald's sounds like an Irish pub not
like you know what is Nike mean what is
what does Google mean they don't mean
anything until the person makes it and
so for me I think that brands are made
and handles people will find what
they're actually looking for so I'm not
crippled by having different things I
prefer you have the same it's easier for
customers but I don't think it's
devastating I would also argue that your
name is generic like right it's just
generic and I think too many people
think in search terms and tried think
too technical instead of making a name
I'd you know I'd rather be called URIs
exercise because it's ownable and it's
more distinct then for it to be a
generic term but that's your choice but
I think to answer your question directly
I'm not crippled by a different Twitter
handle or Instagram handle whine text a
platform that I have for my dad's
business which is going really well all
the social handles are wine text with an
extra s because we couldn't get wine
text so we had a force
we even had a by the URL with an S
because we knew the social handles we're
gonna have an S so you know why text so
I'm not crippled by that I think it's
the execution gotcha and another thing -
you just said you like to try new [ __ ]
[Laughter]
so I was wondering would you be willing
to try a 30-day guarantee in training
with garyvee like an online type of
training I wouldn't just cuz you know I
appreciate the question I appreciate the
right hook I think for me it's um I just
I don't like to put my name behind stuff
that I don't control more I'm passionate
about at that moment so that's why I
wouldn't but I appreciate your asking
Thank You Man I really appreciate it
brother
take care of man thank you so much talk
to you soon
you
you
awesome
Brad how are you
very well I were you Gary yeah man I got
a UH keep that baseball alive man while
we get a little downturn bro like we are
my fantasy baseball draft is like my
favorite thing in the world that it was
literally supposed to be yesterday so I
was like in this sad sad state so what's
good well so so I took your advice about
nine months I stopped watching you
and about two years ago I started my own
business I got it from that a lot of my
a lot of fans have reached out to me
that like well I stopped watching you
and then like three months later I'll
get an email and they're like so listen
when I stopped watching you I started
watching this stuff and actually was
crapping and then I spent $10,000 on
this mastermind like no no no the theory
of act on all the stuff you know so
anyway I hope hopefully hopefully that
means you went into action mode yeah
that's absolutely right so it came from
that San Diego video that you just
ranted on that hotel room and I just I
told myself when I was employee back
then that I would not become an
entrepreneur
I will definitely stop watching Gary and
act so two years ago started my own
business with a partner in mind and as I
tested and tried a bunch of things along
the way I found out what I was doing was
actually what I really loved you know so
started a sales and marketing business
around architectural building products
out here in Seattle so there's a lot of
a lot of action going there I have a
good strong Network and and we were
preparing for the last four or five
months to expand and go from a three
employees to four employees so we are
super super new and and I was about to
make the move this month and then all of
a sudden you know is this what I the
biggest lesson I've learned over this
entrepreneurial journey is that it's
it's sure there's a lot of things that I
know how to do and and I can analyze and
I can get there but there's just grit
right that this answer
northing takes right there's this grit
of like you know the stomach for it yes
it's a different breed than people don't
realize like you it's this things you've
got the ability of a stomach to anxiety
24/7 65 you're a firefighter you're a
guy like you're always on there is no
big I mean do you understand how chill I
would be right now if I was in college
or in high school I'd be pumped as to be
the greatest I keep thinking like [ __ ]
why didn't come gonna happen in 1993 if
I had three months off of school I would
have lost my [ __ ] mind and happiness
and I have a thousand employees to take
care of all this [ __ ] on my shoulders no
that's exactly right I mean and then
talking with these prospective employees
and trying to basically craft and listen
to their awareness and then understand
like hey this is ours and this is what
we're gonna be and then this thing hits
and along the way I'm just thinking the
entire time while everybody's digging
eyes AG right it's a there's an
opportunity here that I don't know if
I'm super clear on yet but I do I do
still feel that gut feeling of t expand
while there is a contraction of
perception of contraction in place you
know I mean this is this is exactly the
amount of fortunes and when I say
fortune I mean happiness and Finance
fortunes that are going to be made
during this next 12-week period is
enormous right wait it's uh using a
different using the Seahawks metaphor
instead of a Mariners most people are
gonna go into prevent defense and get
touchdown I'm gonna blitz and create a
sack and pick up the scoop the football
up and score and win uh I think that's
right now the reason I'm gonna blitz is
because I've done all the right things
for the last decade to have a secondary
that's gonna protect me aka for anybody
who doesn't follow the football analogy
I can go on the offense right now
because I've left a lot of money on the
table over the last decade because I've
saved and I've been on the flip side to
your point
like let's say you have been saved if
you're just starting yes there's an
enormous opportunity you need to be able
to get through three or four months here
clearly and I think you know looking at
China looking at South Korea looking at
other places this is this doesn't look
like it's the Black Plague it doesn't
look like we're gonna lose a hundred
million people to death yeah you know I
you know the government is cleared and
so stimulus packages and so look like
there's a lot of reasons to believe if
like if you can get through a hundred
days of pain there might be a lot of
prosperity on the other side I I think
it's practical to go any offense on
these hundred days and that's that's
there it's really timely this
conversation I've been I've tried I
don't know over the last four years to
connect with you in various ways and for
it to come it like today right like this
is it's it's incredibly timely and and
there's always this serendipitous moment
for it and it's just man I just I want
to I see that opportunity and I can see
these different cracks in this this
place happen and for me in my industry
we were in that construction industry is
left behind in 2008 and ten everybody
departed so there's a strong lack of
resources and trained people to actually
do it and I've been basically creating
this network and then now I want to suck
them into like just work for us and go
after it and they're all sitting at the
precipice of saying yes and going after
it now it's like that grit moment that
chest moment of like I've done my
analyzation I've done this thing it's
time to take the leap and Gary that's
something that that that you don't read
in the business book right
you don't look on Instagram on you know
it so I come in the form of a quote for
me I think what how I see this brother
is life is about alternatives okay
reason you have to do it is if you don't
in 39 years you're gonna be sitting on
the porch eating like [ __ ] why did I do
it 39 years old didn't yesterday you
know and so like
you know what I don't want is seven
world you sitting there with regret I'd
rather you jump fail at Z and not yeah I
I think people don't understand how much
regret is the greatest thing of talking
to eighty nine year olds which I find
myself doing a lot of times in airports
and random [ __ ]
yes I'm an old soul and I've become that
it is you all the time I'm all they talk
about is the things they didn't do yeah
look in eighty nine-year-old in a
nursing home right now and she's gonna
tell you like she wished she married
Bobby Thomson instead of Rick and he
wishes that she started the business but
that was not the era when women did it
and he's gonna say you know Don's gonna
say that he wishes he did move to st.
Louis to the big nobody ever talks about
the [ __ ] they failed everybody always
talks about the [ __ ] they didn't do yeah
you're not gonna if you're if you're
wrong and you take on this risk and the
business start over it's not gonna feel
good and I'll take you a couple years to
test yourself off but you'd be 45 and
you'll move on with your life great well
it's gonna be it's gonna sit there
forever and you're gonna regret forever
you know no it makes me emotional
actually thinking about it that what
changed my perception with you was um I
still think about it his episode Gary
daily as weekly daily V episode 28 I
wish and I want and you mentioned again
today and I remember walking through a
assisted living center that we had
designed and built and done from there
and I remember seeing this 85 year old
guy coming to sit in the lobby and I
remember I had to sit in the lobby to
wait for this other meeting to happen
and I just watched him this is right
after I watched that episode and calm
him down the elevator he walks 15 feet
sits down in the lobby and that was his
that was his walk for the day and I
remember looking at that thinking about
the perspective of really I wish and
going I do not want to the guy when I'm
that guy there one's nothing
and and much like you know for
everybody's listening right I was 28 to
50 much like all the things you thought
about as a kid and now here we are
you're gonna be that 78 year old you're
gonna be that 80 year old you're gonna
be that 90 year yet and so well I think
you're in the right mindset and I think
I think that this this moment is gonna
lead to a lot of opportunity and I think
you know the answer it's very clear to
me you know the answer you know just
don't you know you've clearly analyzed
like right how much risk reward you know
Larry homeless and things that nature
like but put yourself in a practical
offensive position and go crack to go
offensive position all right man I got
this and one other question if there's
any other daily tactics that you do to
just basically take that mindset and
switch it because there's so many
different things of wins that change
during the back all my time on worst
case scenario okay
that's all I did people and it's funny
it's counterintuitive people think I'm
so offensive all I do every second is
think if this all goes wrong am i okay
with going back into a studio apartment
in Queens and the answer is yes yeah I
just wrote my wife a letter the other
day I just said there is no regrets that
I've got over over the 15 years that
we've been married and if I was to do it
over again the way we did it over again
I would do whatever it takes every
single day all the time how do you
brother listen to me what I would do is
think about when you hire these four
people or one person's right I'll go to
six and you go for it and if the market
didn't respond the way you wanted you'd
feel bad that you let those people down
and they have to go back to other jobs
you have your whole life to make it one
of the things I spend a lot of time on
it's whoever's collateral damage for my
mistakes I always think I have my whole
life to make it up to them you know for
example I never raised capital before so
when I raise some money for empathy from
all my friends my business friends I've
never said this publicly but in my mind
I said if this fails I'm just gonna pay
them all back you know over time right
cuz I would be able to pay it all at
once and so like right yes
you know you're in control yes that's
the that's the thing here is that I've
never been in that position in my life
and I always told myself when I'm there
I know I'm going to enter with no
regrets and now that I'm here that chest
that grit that love that I've got it's
it's this it's this really dichotomy of
this motivating factor but then you feel
this like strain of holding back it's
such a it's a very passionate feeling
that it's just so different to define
you know what I mean it's it's it's a
it's being 100% accountable it's not yes
to blame anybody else this is not no
longer your bosses or the company's
fault right
I get it brother I live it every day and
I I've lived it pretty much my whole
life and so I understand here's the good
news put it into worst-case scenario
when I think the sentence when this
fails I'll be happy because I did it and
then I'll do this and hope and and if
you don't if you don't risk the house
you know right by a $28 Mariners teacher
who gives a [ __ ] I wish you well Brad
thank you Gary that was a good one
that's good Gary how are you man how are
you I'm excellent I'm excellent it's
pretty amazing actually to be able to be
on a call with you so I'm pretty excited
about that what's cooking well you saw
my question you know so I I i sell
restaurant point of sale software so I
help restaurant owners you know make
their businesses more efficient help
them run their business grow their sales
and so forth and with this shutdown man
it's it's just affecting all of them and
so I'm just curious as to what ideas you
might have for them to help them through
it I mean for them they've got a they've
got a reengineer their infrastructure to
be able to do local delivery or we've
got the savings to whether the one
hundred twenty-five hundred you know
this could be for restaurants and public
places you could be looking at you know
three fourths of a year because even
when we opened back up I think there's
gonna be hesitation from hat you know
it's gonna be a little while for public
places to get all the way back because
even if we open up in three months you
know I know my mom and you know other
people that are like you know kind of
scared scared are gonna be a little less
excited about going you know there'll be
a whole group of that couldn't wait to
go out so there'll be that pent-up but I
don't you know could be a little while
before it gets to even steven so I think
there's two things one they've got to
innovate and they've got to innovate in
two ways from a branding standpoint or
from an operational standpoint either
they build out significant delivery
infrastructure so it's not only the
ability to have Jordache or uber eats or
you know seamless pickup from them it's
also the ability to have the
capabilities of prepping those meals and
things of that nature but it's also
building up awareness in marketing so
that people choose their restaurant
versus a different one and number two I
think they need to make content if I
owned the restaurant right now if you in
restaurant by myself and I would
literally walk if I was a if I was a
owner chef I would make a video of every
single dish we have on the menu
and show how I make it yn done did it
and looks like I wouldn't have invented
it but say alright here's our
cheeseburger obviously we need a
cheeseburger because we [ __ ] sell
cheeseburgers all day long here's how we
think about it here's a stove I chose
you don't clean it that's the top you
know how people like to do that with the
grill that gives it the extra flavors
I'm big on tomatoes I pick up my
tomatoes from cow hey cow big shout-out
cow and are you struggling out there I
love you brother like I think people
have to tell their story I think that
you know then I would go to my bar and
then literally be the you know
mixologist and explain every drink we
make this is the time to tell your story
I would make fifty to a hundred videos
of why we started the restaurant how
long we've been here how I negotiated
the lease my favorite customers war
stories classic stories every dish at
like this is the time to tell the world
your story I think of it right now is
this I think the corona virus has caused
us all to be into one huge virtual
campfire in the [ __ ] 1300 so we need
to go around and tell a judge other our
stories which is what we used to do pre
television pre [ __ ] everything radio
we used to sit around and tell [ __ ]
stories from the [ __ ] heart
and from the brain and I think every
small business right now needs to tell
their story why they started their
business how they started their business
more stories aka bad things that have
happened hero stories aka great things
that happened and then go in the detail
of their business you know I would walk
around my [ __ ] restaurant be like
here's why we take these chairs
I've never any [ __ ] money I bought
him at a garage sale the sign came for
like tell the world your story in the
form of 50 videos the end I think
everybody should do that kind of percent
yeah I agree we've already been talking
to some people like that like grab your
phone go out in front of your restaurant
like we're open right take him on a tour
like you said take him through the
restaurant show them all the chairs
sitting up on the tables right and tell
their story show the kitchen show the
food all those ideas yeah and for all
the owners that are watching right now
who are introvert and like [ __ ] I can't
do that I'm
scared the camera I don't like the way I
look use use an employee you know you
know inevitably you know obviously we
need social distancing so maybe they
needs to be six feet away from you but
like if you're Cook's funny if you're
maitre d's charismatic if a if a busboy
who's been with you for six weeks just
happens to be good a gift of gab maybe
you know a lot of people my dad for
example needs me to be on camera with
him and then he's good but he doesn't
like it or is not as capable solo so
maybe you're the owner and you just need
a number a second person to bounce off
of because it's you know you got to find
the way that you become comfortable but
you have to put out content and
communicate it's it is everyone sitting
at home and you're one viral video away
from changing your business and more
importantly you put them on YouTube and
you're one even if you never go viral if
you make one video about your Greek
salad that kind of does well on search
results in your area in in a year from
now you might be getting fifteen new
customers a month just because of the
one Greek salad video you made that
happened to do well on YouTube or Google
tik-tok is a huge opportunity right now
you know like just get get creative get
silly but every will succeed 10x and
that's the way the game is played yeah
yeah 100% the creator's over the Criers
yeah well baby you got to think
differently you gotta innovate you got a
you know brother like [ __ ] like I've
been yelling about this for a decade
like make content for the internet think
differently like [ __ ] take your
iphone walk into your restaurant and
make a hundred videos I'm giving you the
blueprint right now here it is make a
video for every single product you sell
on your menu literally make a video for
literally every product you sell on your
on your menu and if you want to do a
how-to you how you make it cuz you're
again an owner chef rate if you're an
owner and the chef comes in and social
distance and you make it like like this
is a yes / no this is a create over cry
this is a do over dwell mindset all we
are so lucky in the if this happened in
1984 there is no internet so brand my
restaurant friends
they're like oh we're so unlucky like
you know you'd the Internet you're awful
so lucky yeah yeah let me ask you
another question more from my
perspective right so I struggle with I
don't want to be that guy coming in to
try to sell you a new POS system when
you are facing shutting your business
down or no business at all and I've had
some of my contacts tell me you know you
have something great to offer you a tool
that can help these restaurant owners so
be that guy but it's all about how you
be that guy look I think I think to your
point I think you need to make I would
struggle to try to sell a POS right now
right I would be putting out content I
would be making videos about you know I
would make a video from you right now
right that's titled why I'm not selling
my POS system right now and I would just
make that video be like hey talk to a
bunch of people now making pretend um
you like talk to a bunch of my friends
associates ironically serendipitously I
was in QA with Gary be like and you know
he said it right for me you know or said
it wrong he said this but from it
doesn't matter whatever your truth is
but I would make a video saying why I'm
not you would say look I just don't feel
like I can right now so instead I'm
gonna be making videos about the value
of POS like I'm like I be making I'm
gonna make videos that are titled like
hey I think you making a video now like
hey I tried to convince you because you
were old school and you like paper and
cash to do POS that didn't work now the
coronavirus is hit and it's hurt your
business one of the ways you can
business can survive is you not having
inefficient overhead that a POS system
can amortize out the value over two
years so you know like I would make
content for post Corona now with your
downtime I would hear me make a video
right now call now the corona is over
it's time to get a [ __ ] POS system
because like be more efficient you know
like right become the guy who like
literally just gives tips on things that
people could be doing for their business
well we're doing
that to try to build those relationships
you know and and and kind of like hey
listen you know give right give give
give right like well I can help
I've got other skillsets other than
selling POS I can help you with your
Facebook page and your Google my
business page and we're setting people
up with online ordering right like you
should have had all this stuff in place
before but you did it and now you're
scurrying to do it and you're being your
eyes are being opened to new revenue
streams that you'll be able to take
advantage of in the future I'm gonna be
sloppy and take shortcuts and overpay
for things yeah like this is where you
get to be your confidant and maid lead
to you being the person they choose to
do a POS with them that's exactly right
yeah yeah cuz there's guys out there
right now that are they're doing it
wrong they're taking advantage of the
situation for charging people out the
nose to set up these makeshift online
ordering solutions and they're not
integrated and they're not going to be
sustainable right they're just taking
advantage of it
look my blueprint is very simple like
bring as much value for free as possible
and that may lead to serendipity if that
leads to somebody hiring the sacha group
if that leads to somebody signing up to
one text if that leads to somebody
buying empathy or my sneakers and
there's no even expectation to me it's
just the Karma practicality of if you're
providing the most value in the world
there's going to be things that work in
your favor
like you know to me you know I'm not
hard you know the amount of people that
I'd like change their business life who
still go to a supermarket and buy a $20
wine instead of signing up for empathy
wines is like tens of thousands and that
doesn't even bother me like doesn't even
bother me you know because I've signed
up for karma practicality and so yeah
that's exactly right brother I think it
worked
excellent excellent I learned a lot from
you man I appreciate it thank you take
care
hello hello can you hear me and
Catherine how are you I'm good I really
excited that thank you how are you well
it's good to see you oh my god
I'm like freaking out I wanted to go on
that top shelf and look up all those
stuffed animals on a lot of them were
webkinz and a lot of them they did sell
on eBay but these are the ones that are
left you have a poster of me on your
wall so my question is basically what
advice you might have for fiction
writers for the internet so I've written
a few novels working on more don't plan
to ever stop I'm 20 now in high school I
thought oh I'm gonna send out my books
I'm gonna get an agent and then it'll
all be easy-peasy from there that didn't
happen but the more I think about it the
less sense that model makes to me anyway
because it seems like you're giving a
lot of leverage to other people to build
your audience for you and do everything
for you and so the more the last few
weeks especially I've been really
thinking that just doesn't make sense to
me but I'm really at a loss as to where
to go from here well what what I mean
where you go from here is you shall you
obviously print yourself and you go
direct to consumer right yeah and so the
way the way I was thinking about is I
feel like I have a lot of options I'm
not sure if I should do all them do one
of them this has just been occurring to
me in the last few weeks so I've been
thinking Wattpad just straight to
Wattpad I've been thinking ebooks and
just messaging everybody on Goodreads
and saying hey do you want to read this
I've been thinking let's take it up a
level because obviously you're educated
enough to know Wattpad and Goodreads and
so you're in tactic knowledge which is
awesome good for you
let's go up a notch I think what you do
is actually get people to care about
characters that's how you actually
summarized it wasn't really stands out
are you what stands out for me is can
you find a designer illustrator and
team up with her him and actually start
Instagram a Catholic for me if I was
gonna sell you know a fiction book I go
into the mindset of like first let me
start the Instagram account and the
tic-tock account of Donnie the dragon
before I even think about selling the
book because if God forbid aka God
willing I can get people to give a [ __ ]
about Donnie the dragon and selling the
book becomes the easier part of it so I
think what you should think about is
micro little writings even let me give
you some that's been on my mind for a
long time for writers that aren't
designers that don't feel comfortable
can't afford or don't know how to team
up with a designer even if you drew
stick figures mm-hmm literally you and
so this is Carol and then in the
Instagram post wrote 12 sentences and
started building up the profiles of the
characters I you know the functionality
you already know you answer to me the
functionality of monetization of
direct-to-consumer writing looks like
you not so what you what you already got
the 101 the 201 course and really
probably the 301 course is how do we get
people to give a [ __ ] about those
characters before you're even done with
the book so that you know again I always
say this you I don't know if you've been
watching but like the gentleman who has
a [ __ ] ant farm on ticket to me
do you write towards a certain age group
like a stable super awesome the most
recent one is young adult but the more
the older I get it's more moving out of
that right now
you're enough you know obviously young
adult on tic-tock I think that's crazy
potential even if you just sat and
talked about it like even if you just
made a video of you just sitting in this
room with this background which i think
is perfect
hey gonna be running a book it's a story
about Sal and Lisa you know like I just
getting people to give a [ __ ] is your
game not necessarily the functionality
of how not to you know I again this is
what makes me smile you
ready know the different model than
getting an agent and having Barnes and
Nobles and Amazon sell it need to give
you the one-on-one answer I need to get
you to think about how do you get people
to care about it if I was writing
fiction I would be putting out content
about the story every day during the
year I was writing the book so by the
time the book came out everybody was
dying to read it mm-hmm that makes a lot
of sense thank you oh yeah well
creatively I'm gonna be very weird here
even if you took to the puppets or the
stuffed animals I'm not kidding I'm like
hey I don't know what they're visually
gonna look like but let's just call this
rabbit Steve and let's just call this
you know bear ruff I'm gonna this is how
I'm gonna do content so Steven I don't
know what feels comfortable to you but
Mister Rogers was a hit right like
Archie comics was a hit I don't know if
you can draw I don't I give you the
stick figure I gave you the buck
straight to camera I don't care what it
takes I don't want you to be reliant on
somebody else to not make I need you to
make you need to do right people will
dwell that they can't afford a
illustrator
no no they can draw stick figures people
will dwell that they don't have a great
studio I'm telling you to [ __ ] just
make videos right like this because I
think the backgrounds charming well
people will say they can't and I want
people to be doers and I want people to
be creators can't needs to be a creator
dwelling needs to be a doer no needs to
be a yes and that's how you get
somewhere so I have one that's ready
right now do you think there's any do
you think there would be any purpose in
waiting or should I get that out and do
the content simultaneously I would
probably take 30 days of trying to build
up content before I released it to your
point because it's ready just to even
test out my theory you know look you
know this if you put it out now and you
email your email list and you put that
out in your small social media and you
spam people on Goodreads you're only
going to get so much action
right so reality is is that I think
you're better off trying the concept we
have in place of like building up a
little bit of a narrative there'll be
good muscle for you to learn how to try
to do it
makes sense I think we might have lost
category Dustin women have lost
Katherine thank you so much
let's move on
yeah yes
are we good here look look see my dad he
says how are you good hey you life I
think it's gone quick oh man what's up
man how do you pronounce your name miss
I n but you need combination that's cool
sure yeah no I love I love that name
it's just like Caesar but uh man this is
crazy
this is surreal man this is very super
over here this is odd so my question is
basically I I've grown up with some
great just to give you context great
parents immigrants from Mexico and they
became so since my dad when he was like
20 and my mom and she was younger and
basically they raised this there is me
my sister really well but I felt like
from my dad's side he did a great job of
structuring stuff and making sure I have
a good work that they can stuff a god
but for my mom side I felt very like
like if life had to be a lot of fun all
the time and that created yakeen I can't
really hear you I can hear I'm listening
it's very interesting that he put an
emphasis that life has to be fun
my mom did yeah actually she put a big
emphasis that their life had like
basically that every moment I couldn't
be sad and that stuff had be fun and we
never really complained in the house if
you think that but what's happened is
there's been a and and I've kind of got
it now this guy started watching a
content called months ago but basically
I got to a point where my dad took away
my allowance and I felt like I deserved
it okay yeah you know what I mean
getting it
and I was like when did this happen this
happened maybe year and a half ago maybe
how old are you if not a year ago I'm 18
don't ya and basically it got me it got
me feeling wearing now I was like well
you know I'm just gonna have to figure
stuff out now just whatever and my Lance
wasn't that big or anything but it just
felt like maybe happened like two years
ago
I don't know um you thought that they
were taking advantage of you that you
entitled to it that there was some
[ __ ] yeah I felt a little bit like
like wow these are my they're my parents
like they should be hooking it up a
little bit you know what I mean and and
it was crazy
What did he say he said you're grown ask
me now
stop no more allowance basically
basically this video and I like him even
more now no he's great he's a great dad
but there's a time there was a time when
he was the like what we call him and
maoli la película which basically means
a bad guy this is a bad guy one point
because you know with my mom it was all
fun and whatever and that's common yep
yep and but now man I respect him so
much because sorry watching content and
started started realizing that I was
entitled and I was like what the heck
because that was it wasn't only the
allowance thing but several several
other little stuff and he just it's
sorry to liberate me but now I'm at the
point where I'm starting to work for him
cuz you know school got shut down and
not stuff and also my schedule is pretty
loose because I'm a senior in high
school and so I go to school for like
the first half of the day and then I'll
go work for him
the second half from like 12 before what
does he do where you are an electrical
company things an electrician in now
attrition for 28 years so that's where
I'm going into and but anyways to get to
the actual question I'm sorry
or consistently like a 20 hour workweek
soon to be 40 after I graduated and
sometimes I find myself during the week
like there's days where I love it and
I'm having a good time in whatever and
there's days that I won't write and I
kind of feel like I'd rather stay home
and play on my drum set because that's
something that I realize that kind of
like to do you have time to do you only
and that's man this is what I want to
talk to you because I was like man I
just don't know I'm like you talk about
diving into your passions and stuff but
I'm like I want to also provide a
support for a future family what you
know but then but then it's like you say
that not everyone's life is gonna be
like yours and that we can have the
work/life balance if we want it and so
so first of all back to like when I
think about ingredients like you have so
many good ingredients like I love your
perspective 4818 I like the
thoughtfulness I love that you're over
the hump on entitlement I am obsessed
with the admiration and respect you have
towards your parents you remind me a lot
of me at 18 right now because I just had
a lot of that I think the one thing that
I was able to do was I worked a lot more
than you did because and still thought I
did have time to look at my baseball
cards play Genesis like I think that my
work ethic might have been more on point
than yours is to be free no Evan trip
talking that hours of work and in that
20 hours you're like damn I wish I was
on my drum set and like [ __ ]
you could be on yours and soon to be 40
hours I laughed in my head on some real
[ __ ] is it 40 like 40 I was 85 90 like
real [ __ ] hours and yeah like if
you're gonna work 40 you have a ton of
[ __ ] time to [ __ ] bang on your
[ __ ] drums you know and try side
hustles and hang out with friends and
live your life sorties nothing mm-hmm
it's nothing and and and what I mean by
that is you're in a great spot because
you love this like if you're talking an
18 about future family you got that
[ __ ] in your soul which love like what
do you say huh you have that immigrant
practicality yeah it's almost 18 year
olds don't think about providing for a
future family so I'm glad you're in that
practical place a bro on some real [ __ ]
forties nothing like yeah Woody's
nothing like I don't even know how to
explain it to you like I feel like you
have an ability to eat like have some
grit and eat some crow and pay your dues
yeah I've got good news for you if it's
really 40 you got off easy family miss
second-generation like that [ __ ] usually
looks more like 67 82 like if you're a
weight have tons of time between 18 and
30 to put in to your side hustle of
starting a YouTube channel around drums
to hang out to like I mean [ __ ] 40 are
you [ __ ] kidding me
you [ __ ] hit the lottery if it's 40
my Friday Saturday my Thursday Friday
and Saturday of every summer day and
since I was 14 was 47 to 8 p.m.
13 hours times three like [ __ ] 40
you're [ __ ] set I'm real happy for you
because I think you're gonna be able to
check every box you're gonna be able to
help the family business
help yourself make some money but you
still have a hundred [ __ ] hours in a
week to [ __ ] sleep spend time with
friends and do your side hustle you're
fortunate know here's here's what I
don't want no cabin and it's like right
now I feel good and I have that drive
but what do I do
when tomorrow I feel that like like man
that was great with Gary yesterday right
now you know we're back to it and it's
like cool and then and then the next
week slowly progresses down high right
now tomorrow you go hard but then in two
weeks you're back to that place with two
hours into the day of electronically
like [ __ ] I wish it so listen this is
what being a man and this is what being
an
greater in life is about learning how to
get comfortable with the uncomfortable
is there you know what I mean brother
yeah we're gonna get comfortable with
the uncomfortable you said learning to
like longer in that zone at 11 a.m. in
you know on July 19th when you're like
you're like [ __ ] man I wish I was home
playing drums or I wish I was with my
boy Salvatore right now learning to get
over that hump is is very required right
like that isn't people are you know we
are so lucky we're so lucky that a lot
of people don't want to get a
relationship with being uncomfortable
they just want everything to be awesome
is like it's it's such macro entitlement
as if everyone's life should always be
awesome at all times I don't this is you
know don't create this narrative in your
mind of blaming your mom that everything
has to be happy is why you're incapable
yeah
that's not your mom trying to make
positives out of negatives that's you
our [ __ ] so lucky that you had such
great parents that provide a dream that
you are not in a place yet where you're
like you're starting this incredible
process of getting out of entitlement
and I'm proud of you mm-hmm so now what
you need to do is kinda like working out
it's like kind of debt extra 10 pounds
on the wheel this summer get those Reds
get those reps that's exactly right man
I love that you understand like like
every time you read 11:30 in the morning
and somebody yells at you at the job and
you're like [ __ ] man I could just be
home playing xbox every time you do that
you go into my [ __ ] parents
immigrated to America when they were my
age
they were [ __ ] scared shitless of
making it in America they didn't have a
[ __ ] pot to piss in and I'm sitting
here complaining about a [ __ ] family
business that my dad create on his
[ __ ] back that I can go to gratitude
go to gratitude mm-hmm I just gotta
train it because because because the
main thing that was confusing me is I
was like I don't know like cuz you talk
about you know if you don't like going
or whatever then you shouldn't be doing
that but the thing was that I was doing
it some I was
sometimes it's not like you know time so
then I was like you know what let's to
do here but you just man you send me
with the unmarked yeah so real because
what's what's funny about them it's like
look unhappiness is not is is not
something people should do but to your
point and this is why I love doing QA
when I say don't do something that you
don't love I don't mean don't do
something you don't love for an hour
I mean don't let that be your 80 year
career yeah like it's real to me I also
say eat [ __ ] and like I believe in
eating [ __ ] like we just talked about it
in detail here 11:30 July 19th
you know Miguel on the job yells at you
and says that kid you [ __ ] idiot
you're like you know like yeah yeah like
that's the moment you take a step back
and you think about this conversation
and you're like right when my dad was my
age when your dad was 18 you're 18 or 18
or said I'm 18 I'm 18 under that was 18
tell me exactly what he was doing if you
know he was hustling doing he was he was
installing like video game machines in
Mexican likes it called like not really
bars but more just like kind of
convenience stores he would go into I'll
tell you a story real quick he would go
into the store and tell the the owners
be like hey you mind if I nice all these
things for you here and there but no I
don't want any I don't want any little
toys or anything and then he back here
let me leave him here for a day and then
I'll come back tomorrow
pick him up and if you still don't want
him you know and then basically he would
leave him there a bunch of kids would
come playing them and buy stuff from the
store and then the store and there
should be like oh [ __ ] okay I won yep
bro your dad was grinding mmm your dad
didn't love installing [ __ ]
videogames and [ __ ] creams and
[ __ ] you know but like drunk you have
your whole life in front of you you you
absolutely need to build a relation
almost under 30 in America yeah anybody
needs to find a relationship with
adversity and getting comfortable with
eating [ __ ] and I think it'd be a great
summer for you like
and you know 40 thing is huge to me I'm
so bro when I wouldn't explain to you
how lucky I think you are sort the whole
[ __ ] rest of the week I don't care if
it's really 40 is it gonna be really 40
which is great okay he said 40 to 50 he
said 40 or 50 if you wanted to want an
bro listen man let me tell you something
I thought I was the hardest working
person I knew when I was 28 years old
running wine library I [ __ ] worked
all day you know 8 a.m. to [ __ ] 8 p.m.
every day that was soft compared to Who
I am now at 44 I go harder stronger
smarter this is about [ __ ] reps and
gaining muscles right your you've got
your stocky dude I'm looking at you
right now
you know that if you worked out like a
[ __ ] maniac for a year eight right
lifted weights you'd be a [ __ ]
monster cuz you got that build you know
that I had mentally I had that [ __ ]
built mentally but it was some [ __ ]
reps for you that may be [ __ ]
completely unstoppable look at this like
you're going into training you're going
into training forty hours a day to
[ __ ] put calluses on your [ __ ]
hands and create thickness to your skin
to your [ __ ] dome
you're crazy go understand this is you
going to training yes you need to be
like Rocky and [ __ ] rocky this is
about going in the snow like go into
this like holy [ __ ] I'm so lucky that I
get to go into training I'm gonna get
paid to try [ __ ] trained how to be a
[ __ ] mental assassin for the rest of
my life
you're watching yeah that's so real yeah
bro and you get to do with your dad
[ __ ] look you're so [ __ ] lucky
most people that are watching right now
have to do it for a boss they don't know
the greatest thing that ever happened to
me is the memories of being inches with
my dad you know like I you know it's
crazy that I get to have those memories
one day my dad's gonna be gone and I'm
gonna be so happy about those hours I
put in those war stories you understand
yeah and I'm crying because I'm happy
because I'm this is I was
the beds and I didn't want to leave
because I liked the electrical but I
didn't want to leave to try to get a job
in in drumming right because I was like
I like both I like working with my dad
and so this this was really the unlock
for me you know that's why that's what
I'm feeling it man
eight hours a week drumming YouTube
channel you can [ __ ] them looking
robbing come you can work at and
drumming company at night forty okay
great gigs yeah you have so much time
and you're gonna gain a strength you're
gonna gain a strength yeah that's so
real like just being good at being
uncomfortable in being like hey you know
this is kind of boring but I'm gonna get
through it because you know my family
built this and you know I'm so grateful
for the opportunity to even have that
because a lot of people my age coming
down to high school don't know what they
want to do don't have a job right and
you're gonna you're gonna learn a skill
you're gonna learn how to interact with
grown-ass men learn how to interact with
customers that are upset you're gonna
watch your dad versity you're gonna
learn you're getting an education a
training and you're gonna get paid you
should be paying your dad yeah oh man oh
grateful that I decided that when I was
I realized that 22 that I had it and I
decided instead of going build something
for myself cuz I could I knew the
Internet
I knew the [ __ ] in I knew the hustle I
[ __ ] knew it I was making $500 $1,000
when I was 13 I was 22 I was a grown-ass
man I didn't need to go into my dad's
business for me I needed to go into my
dad's business for me emotions I wanted
to give back because I knew I could and
I knew I was gonna learn a lot of stuff
you know no did it feel great to not
have a lot of money because in a family
business you really never pay yourself
that much you know if I was an executive
team illya not even paid a million a
year but was you know but but those
memories with my dad and doing something
that giving
back to my parents who came to this
country with nothing and built the
foundation that I stand on that's
something I'll never regret and you're
gonna have that opportunity if I [ __ ]
only did forty hours a week I would
probably start a Facebook heart starting
lineups eBay flipping business on the
side too and gotten doubled
you know like happy so like yeah you
really have a good bro and it's so crazy
that you say that because of the fact
that like literally only like a week and
a half ago I told my mom and I just
talked with her and I was like man I'm
so grateful for you guys because it's
cuz I just got I just felt this
gratitude wave of like ma'am soul a hope
I just didn't know how to apply it to
the work thing because I was I was
confused I'm like whether or not you
know but man it's it's it's it's all
about the perspective of like man when
I'm older I'm gonna be able to look back
and say I got to work with my dad I got
to do the 40 hours like you said and I
can still do my other stuff and let me
know you could go 80 hours for seven
years and [ __ ] be 25 and Young is
[ __ ] both my arms off right now to be
25
you know he's 90 hours a week do no
drums and bounce out of there as a
[ __ ] child
still a child mm-hmm you have you have
everything you have your perspective and
and maturity at 18 any of your whole
life in front of you you got a hundred
more years of life you're gonna look for
a hundred more years bro it's a real
[ __ ] you're part of that lucky
generation you're gonna live to 180 no I
believe that I can see that I can see at
least a hundred place 100 118 you're
gonna live a hundred more listen to me
you will never ever ever regret working
40 to 50 hours a week with your dad for
the next for a long period of time I
promise you that I rarely be that I'm
rarely that definitive but I've spent
enough time with you right now to know
that to be true you've got too much of
that soul and gratitude towards your
parents any kid who's watching right now
who is grateful and loves their parents
for what they did for them
should go into the family business
because even if it's a disaster you'll
always be happy that you paid back a
little bit to the thing that put you on
mm-hmm
man that's so real can we take a photo
real quick
yeah all right ready
I don't know what I'm doing okay so just
a little piece a maybe a little little
rock on for the [ __ ] trailer
all right brother waste hey have a good
one thank you you're welcome
that was epic listen Robert
you
you
Dustin you're [ __ ] up my flow
there is a good one
my pops I get a little teary-eyed
you
you
in Robert
can you see hey what's going on Gary our
things these are amazing my friend how
are you I'm doing well meanwhile are as
well as one could be so can you see
right now I can't even tell here I see
everything okay yeah
no my name is Robert a lot of you know
me as Bobby T I'm from Edmonton Alberta
and Canada you were supposed to come to
the city I think in two days but
obviously because the current landscape
you're not gonna make it I'm working on
organizing to be able to get update in
September okay dope dope that's super
dope so a little bit context about
myself I have like my own marketing
agency here called Bridge me media where
we specialize mainly in content
production we've been also community
management and those kind of like
different lanes and obviously the one
question I kind of had for you I should
have two questions the first question I
have a views like in this clearly
current landscape of things I know
there's like a ton like we've lost a ton
of business just do two people now
holding tight but then also we're
holding on to a couple clients who right
now are in different industries that are
just now working very strong to kind of
engage their current customers and as
like b2b and my question to you is for
right now for people who are having sort
of smaller agencies what would you
recommend our strategy should be in
terms of like trying to grow or navigate
or still yeah just hold on tight here
and so yeah what what would you what are
your thoughts are that things one I
would go heavy into sales mode and heavy
into content mode I would probably do a
lot of LinkedIn and a lot of Twitter
searching and a lot of cold out reach
out and think about companies that are
busy you know restaurants that might be
doing delivery food services like I
because when you're a small business you
need cash and when you lose clients you
know we can get ugly real quick as I'm
sure you know Bobby so one I would if
I'm you so is it your company yes my
company you have employees personal
freedom it's free I
freelancers that work with me so I have
a few that basically I'd like a video
team I have like writers I have like
grab designers we're all local and saw
work items you don't have overhead cuz
you're on the payroll right no so you
know honestly then specifically for you
sales is important but not required
because for example for me I have a
thousand people on payroll like that's
scary [ __ ] as we lose clients you know
so for me one of the things to do now is
to really go on the offense on content
if you've got downtime this is the time
for you to make 500 [ __ ] videos you
know I'm a big fan of what if like I
think one of the biggest mistakes small
small agencies make is they think the
information they have is what they sell
and I think it's the execution so one of
the reasons I put out all my best advice
is I don't mind if a bob ET and Edmonton
picks up on that free information and go
get some business that makes me happy
for karma and - I don't think people
sign with us for my smarts even though
I'm a progressive forward work I think
it's about the execution so I think
right now I would probably if I let me
just make role play I'm probably I'm
probably making 500 YouTube videos
because I think that archives in its
search Bobbie T's what-ifs what if I was
a car dealership in Edmonton during the
coronavirus and post coronavirus and
then just make a video I would literally
do that for like 500 different business
sectors okay that makes sense
time for you to go ham on yourself no
100% and like and I know your your
quality over quantity kind of mindset
and I totally understand that and I'm
blessed and I'm lucky that I have a
really dope studio that I can just
quickly bang out some these items of
stuff I've been building so I really
appreciate that word advice I would
think of people think of
YouTube in subscribers and views I think
about YouTube like a search engine I
think you should get out 500 [ __ ]
videos on YouTube that literally have
the word Edmonton in the title because
they're gonna be king of SMB in that
area or if you want to be if you wanna
make it or Canada or America or the
world like you decide you but think
about in this actually great general
advice think about YouTube like a search
engine
not like Netflix where you're looking
for views and ratings everybody doesn't
make content because they're trying to
make [ __ ] you know they're trying to
make videos I get tons of using its
subscribers and my whole thing is like
no no make us you make videos as a
search engine so that a hairstylist in
Edmonton stumbles on your video on what
marketing you would do if you were a
hairstylist which then leads for them to
reach out to you be like you know I'm a
hairstylist at Edmonton I'd like to pay
you 15 hundredths to [ __ ] do this for
me I would [ __ ] everyone stuck at
home make content you have a studio are
you [ __ ] kidding me make five hundred
to a thousand videos where the title is
a search engine query listen for your
business you get seven a hundred eighty
seven views on what I would do if I was
a butcher in Alberta for my business
you getting 187 views on that leads to
to butcher and you eight hundred dollars
a month for you to be their agency 100
percent know that makes that makes total
sense and and I have a my second
question I just had I'm is actually it's
it's about my wife so my wife she's an
awesome music artist she does kids music
she it's such a great performer and
we're trying to figure out also like
sort of what would be like sort of a
solid strategy for her to grow her Brad
and then in the game of yes canta canta
content and just on the platforms of
pushing the content what we're trying to
figure out is like and you kind of speak
into this early when you're making a
reference point about how for that
individual who's writing books I'm
teaming up a different artists to kind
of create contextual content for like
tick-tock
architectural concept and Instagram and
writing blurbs
get people to care and I'm wondering
what your thoughts around people who are
in the music area specifically around
kids music what should they be doing and
how can they do stuff other than just
making I guess music videos is there is
there other layers that we can kind of
go to create or grow her Brad I think
tick tock is incredibly important if I'm
her she's putting out for tick tocks a
day for to talk today tick tocks a day
cuz tick tock is so viral
did you see the ant farm guy a couple
hours ago yes yes yes I mean for her
it's tick tock I think Facebook because
you're gonna get two moms on Facebook
and Instagram you know uh Facebook group
you know I think let me throw this one
at you I think becoming the moderator of
a Facebook group that is narrow but has
you know as you can imagine for her does
she wanna does she like getting is a
goal of her getting booked by parents to
do events yes so yeah books are
institutions in terms of like local
libraries doing a little sing-alongs for
kids and things like that Facebook group
right now would be huge I also think
live streaming right now cuz parents are
[ __ ] besides themselves having their
kids in their home 24/7 they're looking
for ways to entertain kids this is a
viral moment opportunity for her where
she just goes live and entertains and
like starts a Facebook groups or moms
where moms know that they could just put
their kid on in front of a laptop with
her for from 11:00 to 1:00 every day no
different than what I did from 9:00 to
11:00 right now so like I think Facebook
group where she's the moderator around
kids activities which then leads to
people booking her as long as she's not
trying to sell herself in the group and
every minute but providing value but I
think live screams and I think you tick
tock for tick tocks a day I mean it for
two cups a day video versions of that
will crush every the amount of 13-year
olds on tick-tock that have six-year-old
siblings is remarkable okay so then by
engaging those teenagers who will then
engage their younger brothers or sisters
I'll just go full loop while they'll be
giving the phones to these kids never
thought about like that no that is I'm
30 year old Sarah hey Tiffany this looks
like for you you know
got it yeah yeah yeah yeah no that's
huge you know that's how it works
no it's wicked no preciate preciate all
that and then I haven't asked for you
Gary
so when you when you said that you're
coming to Edmonton I have my own podcast
show it's called 360 chat with just
Bobby T and it would be awesome would
love to interview you when you come to a
meetin
so Bobby yeah I'm gonna make a 90
percent promise cuz I don't know about
logistics I might just fly in and out
but a 90 email me right now Gary at
vaynermedia say it's Bobby and I'll
probably give you 10 minutes in the
green room before I go onstage for a
quick little take wicked though
appreciate that so much
talk to you soon Dustin act all right
it's called a faded media thank you for
everybody who spent two hours with me
this morning I'm gonna try to do a bunch
of these this week next week I mean the
more corona the more tea time with Gary
so Dustin thank you the less the team
thank you watch this morning I wish you
guys nothing but the best
much love
you